[Musique]
bonsoir le covin bouscule la vie des
français depuis un an et puis la vie
politique aussi eu copie le gouvernement
tous les jours pour l'instant le
couvre-feu est la règle en espérant ne
pas avoir à revenir à un confinement
emmanuel macron endiguer en tout cas dit
vouloir l'éviter à tout prix depuis un
an tout cas le coc vide a tendance aussi
à tout écrasé sur son passage
même si des débats sensibles ne sont
annoncés dans les jours qui viennent et
dans les semaines qui viennent notamment
à l'assemblée nationale sur les
principes républicains des débats qui
ont commencé il y a deux heures
maintenant
la gauche et la droite sur ce sujet
attendent le gouvernement au tournant
eh bien on va parler de tout ça ce soir
avec notre invité dans l'audition
publique le rendez vous politique de lcp
public sénat avec le figaro du lundi
soir damien abad
bonsoir les prisons du groupe l'est
républicain à l'assemblée nationale je
rappelle que c'est le groupe
d'opposition le plus nombreux à
l'assemblée nationale on va commencer
par ces restaurateurs dont
l'établissement est fermé depuis trois
mois après avoir été les premiers à
fermer déjà lors du premier conflit il
ya bientôt un an maintenant et qui ont
décidé d'ouvrir malgré tout malgré les
menaces de sanctions d'amande pour
attirer l'attention du gouvernement sur
leur situation pour exprimer leur
ras-le-bol aussi pour eux les aides de
l'état ne suffisent pas bruno le maire
vous allez entendre ce matin les menaces
de sanctions tous ceux qui restent
ouverts à partir du moment où ils font
ce choix de ne pas respecter la règle
seront suspendues pendant un mois de
l'accès au fonds de solidarité
et si jamais il ya récidive ils n'auront
plus accès du tout au fond de solidarité
je pense qu'à partir du moment où nous
sommes généreux nous soutenons
massivement tous ceux qui sont fermés
il faut encore c'est juste et c'est
légitime il est dommage il est légitime
sur les 10 6 juste et légitime que nous
disions clairement ceux qui ne
respectent pas les règles n'auront plus
de soutien de la part de l'état ahmad
c'est normal bon d'abord il faut
comprendre la souffrance économique
social et psychologique de nos
restaurateurs et l'état dans lequel il
se trouve pour certains ça fait sept
mois qui n'exerce plus leur métier pour
vous les comprenez je comprends leur
souffrance mais je ne partage pas la
désobéissance civile et je le dis et je
crois que bruno le maire a raison
pourquoi parce que c'est injuste pour
les restaurateurs qui respecte la règle
pour celles et ceux qui ne font pas de
restaurant clandestins qui respecte les
règles avec courage avec force avec
dignité
moi je pense à cela et d'ailleurs vous
faire une confidence mais restaurateurs
dans le département de l'ain aujourd'hui
ils m'ont interpellé sur ce sujet ce
week end et m'ont dit mais c'est pas
normal parce que nous on respecte la
règle et on veut que cette règle soit
appliquée par tout le monde et on n'a
pas envie d'être représentés ni dans les
médias ni ailleurs par des gens qui
invite à la désobéissance il alors qui
sont ces restaurateurs pour vous ce sont
des délinquants
non c'est s'il s'agit pas de faut
comprendre il ya un moment particulier
il s'agit mais quand on respecte pas une
loi vous savez c'est là d un accord en
mai bruno le maire a raison c'est à dire
que il ya un fonds solidarité à des
dispositifs de soutien ces dispositifs
de social qui sont accessibles quand on
respecte la règle de droit
quand on ne la respecte pas on n'a pas
droit à ces dispositifs
ce que je dis aussi y va au delà il dit
il va falloir fermer administrativement
restaurant et une amende vous êtes vous
vous signez moi je partage ce la wii par
scor vous savez on peut pas demander
matin midi et soir faut de la cohérence
et même quand on est dans l'opposition
envoyée on va pas demander matin midi et
soir un couvre-feu renforcée qui soit
respecté par tous les français et que
quand certains ne respectent pas ce
couvre feu
et bien finalement on laisse faire je ne
crois pas que dira la bonne solution
seulement couvre-feu confinement ou pas
bon on va en parler avec mes consoeurs
des chaînes parlementaires brigitte
boucher d'être cpa sang versé allemand
soir brigitte d'anciens francis et thème
traduit de public sénat pour soir table
face à francis un gîte bas c'est à vous
commencé mon sort damien abad par le
gouvernement a durci les restrictions
sanitaires mais n'a par confiner c'est
ce que vous demandiez en fait est ce que
du coup vous êtes satisfait ce que je
n'ai pas apprécié c'est la mécanique de
la décision c'est que pendant dix jours
on a envoyé tout le ban et l'arrière ban
du gouvernement pour expliquer que on a
l'air confiné que le confinement allait
être serré que ça allait être dur et
donc on a entretenu un climat de peur et
d'angoissé auprès des français pour
finalement à la fin
faire comme je les dis est partout et
tout ça pour ça donc oui je soutiens
l'idée du couvre-feu
parce que je préfère un couvre feu
renforcé à un confinement et parce que
le confinement ça doit être la dernière
étape mais ce que je regrette c'est la
mécanique de la décision et la manière
dont on a inquiété et alimenter la peur
et sur le français comme emmanuel macron
du coup vous faites confiance aux
français oui depuis le début est
d'ailleurs moi je critique tous avaient
tous ceux qui infantilise les français
je crois à l'esprit de responsabilité et
je crois que c'est cela qui est
essentiel aujourd'hui donc
après nous verrons bien comment les
choses vont évoluer enfin si on
confinait dès aujourd'hui et que dans
quinze jours trois semaines ou dans un
mois
les chiffres se dégrade encore plus on
sera peut-être obligé un confinement
pendant deux mois est ce que les
français sont prêts aujourd'hui à cela
je n'en suis pas sûr ce qu'il faut c'est
que le couvre-feu sera respectée en
cadres confinement est ce que vous avez
eu l'assurance du premier ministre que
vous avez vu il y a quelques jours qu'il
y aura un débat parlementaire avec un
vote oui nous l'a dit simplement je
demande qu'une chose c'est que ce débat
parlementaire il ait lieu avant la prise
de parole du président de la république
sur un éventuel confinement parce que un
débat avec un vote quand tout est décidé
ça n'a plus beaucoup d'intérêt ça veut
dire qu'en cas de confinement vous
pouvez envisager de voter contre leur
confinement ça veut dire en tout cas moi
ce que je souhaite c'est qu'on est le
débat à l'assemblée nationale
c'est qu'on puisse voter avant la
déclaration prise en flic au moins avant
l'entrée en vigueur du couvre-feu ça
nous semble être la moindre des choses
et puis complices auraient d'ailleurs ce
débat je le demande pour chaque semaine
je souhaite un débat hebdomadaire à
l'assemblée nationale sur l'évolution de
la crise sanitaire qui est confinement
ou pas parce qu'il ya pas que ce sujet
là et le sujet des vaccins il fait des
tests des sujets il ya beaucoup de
sujets qui sont sur la table et c'est
normal que la représentation nationale
soit associée et aujourd'hui elle ne
l'est pas suffisant casaca vote à chaque
fois non éventuellement voter contre 1
re confinement mais la question elle
n'est pas de savoir si on est pour ou
contre euro confinement d'abord de quoi
on parle
est ce que c'est un recond finement avec
la fermeture ou l'ouverture des écoles
est-ce que les commerces sont fermés ou
pas tout dépend de ce qu'il y à nous ce
que nous voulons c'est trois choses de
la cohérence de la justice et de la
prévisibilité table vous dites que la
représentation nationale n'est pas assez
associé d'ailleurs contrairement au
sénat la mission d'information qu'ovide
à l'assemblée a été dissoute vous
l'opposition est ce que vous allez en
rester là
ce dont on a insisté la semaine dernière
c'est une parodie de démocratie on a vu
la république en marche en pleine crise
sanitaire enterrer une mission
d'information sur la coved qui était le
seul outil que nous avions à disposition
pour débattre de la crise tous ensemble
je le regrette profondément et tous les
groupes d'opposition ont dit la même
chose et on pensait la même chose et
donc vous allez demander quelques jolis
remplacé demain matin je
vais le dire en conférence des
présidents j'ai d'ailleurs écrit au
président richard ferrand pour lui
demander qu'une nouvelle mission
d'information s'installe une mission
d'information issue de la conférence des
présidents
avec l'ensemble des groupes politiques
comme nous l'avons fait pour la première
vague on peut pas matin midi et soir
appelé à l'union nationale est pratiqué
ici matin midi et soir la désunion nash
est ce que vous imaginez richard ferrand
désavoué la majorité me fais guère
d'illusions mais je rappelle que richard
ferrand était celui et il a eu le
courage de le faire qui a été
l'instigateur de cette mission
d'information ladder nous l'avons
proposé ensemble nous l'avons fait
ensemble
d'ailleurs ça s'est bien passé tout le
monde a souligné y compris d'ailleurs
sur la partie commission denquête qu'on
était très loin de la commission
denquête benalla avec un état d'esprit
positif fait de propositions notre
rapporteur général eric ciotti l'a fait
et je souhaite qu'on continue ce même
état d'esprit on va parler aussi de la
question de la vaccination livraisons de
vaccins commandés par l'union européenne
sont un petit peu chaotique car on a vu
ces dernières semaines
est ce que la france a eu raison de
faire confiance à l'europe de miser sur
l'europe dans ce contexte pour vous où
il fallait une commande européenne mais
je crois que à côté de cette commande
européenne on aurait très bien pu faire
comme l'allemagne d'autres pays
avant aussi une commande nationales
spécifiques c'est le vestiaire avec
d'autres pays à l'aider oui le problème
que l'on a aujourd'hui c'est quoi c'est
que on n'a pas suffisamment de doses il
ya une défaillance des laboratoires il
ya une défaillance du gouvernement qui
n'a pas fait de commandes nationales et
il ya aussi malheureusement une
défaillance du vaccin français et c'est
donc cette triple peine pour nous parce
que nous n'avons pas nos propres vaccins
et n'avons pas nos propres commandes et
donc on dit en dépend totalement de la
commande européenne ce qui nous
affaiblit bien sûr considérablement et
je demande une autre chose ce que
philippe g20 a dit c'est qu'il faut
pouvoir acheter les licences des vaccins
ça s'anticipe dès aujourd'hui si on veut
avoir des vaccins demain et après demain
dès aujourd'hui on doit se mobiliser
alors pour l'instant le gouvernement
vacciner en priorité les personnes âgées
celles à sa stratégie
est ce que pour vous il faut cibler
aussi d'autres populations par exemple
le président de l'ue dit jean christophe
lagarde propose de vacciner les jeunes
et il pense surtout aux étudiants
vous savez tout les vaccins toutes les
populations sont prioritaires et que
l'on vaccine les jeunes ou les aînés
c'est important je pense aussi aux
parents et aux personnes handicapées qui
sont aussi pour beaucoup d'entre elles
des personnes vulnérables
pourrait aussi vacciner de manière
beaucoup plus importante et plus rapide
non la réalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui nous
manquons de doses dans tous les
départements de france et d'ailleurs
j'ai créé au sein du groupe l'est
républicain une hotline des territoires
qui nous font des remontées sur la
politique vaccinale dans tous les
départements je peux vous dire dans tous
les départements il n'y a quasiment plus
de doses chez vous dans l'ain par
exemple c'est chez nous dans l'ain nous
faisons quasiment que des deuxième
injection c'est à dire que nous n'avons
plus de primo vaccination et je vais
vous raconter cette anecdote là une dame
de 84 ans est venue au centre de
vaccination dernière à bugey elle avait
pris le premier action de 21 janvier on
lui a donné rendez vous le 22 mars pour
la deuxième lui semaines après mais bon
c'est absolument c'est pas sûr jeu
efficace beaucoup c'est à dire que c'est
scandaleux parce que ça ne correspond
pas à la recommandation de leurs
autorités sanitaires la question sur wii
et jean castex à a rappelé le quoi qu'il
en coûte reste la ligne du gouvernement
à droite vous vous présentez vous comme
les garants des finances publiques est
ce que vous dites vous stop il faut
arrêter cette dépense du quoi qu'il en
coûte
non il y a urgence aujourd'hui à
préserver notre tissu économique
tant que nous serons dans cette
politique de stop and go tant que nous
serons en confinement où on couvre feu
il faut aider les acteurs économiques
il est hors de question d'arrêter les
aides sur le chômage partiel que ce soit
le fonds de solidarité que ça sur
l'accompagnement d'ailleurs il n'ya pas
que l'état qui fait des aides et aussi
toutes les collectivités locales nous
faisons nous au département dans la
région auvergne rhône-alpes également
donc il faut mobiliser ses aises c'est
très important ce que nous disons c'est
quoi qu'il en coûte
oui mais avec une limite quand même
c'est de dire qu'il n'ya pas d'argent
magique et que la dette
on peut pas nous faire croire qu'un jour
il ne faudra pas les rembourser et que
cette question là se pose rapport aux
français et nous disons pour la
rembourser il nous faudra ni augmenter
les impôts des français ni prélever
davantage de charges et d'impôts sur les
entreprises alors pas entrer dans le
débat sur comment parce que ça nous
amènerait trop loin et puis un autre
sujet à aborder c'est cette réforme de
pour renforcer les principes
républicains ça s'est appelée loi contre
le séparatisme certains l'ont appelée
loi contre l'islamisme radical
tam en tout cas c'est un sujet qui va
faire débat pendant les semaines qui
viennent mais oui on vous présentait
d'ailleurs vous demain votre
contre-projet à ce texte comportant les
principes républicains
quelle différence c'est ce qui va ya
voir avec le texte gouvernemental
beaucoup d'abord on va étudier tous les
angles morts qu'il n'y a pas dans ce
projet de loi tout ce dont on n'aborde
pas aujourd'hui la question de la
radicalisation dans les prisons dans les
universités dans les hôpitaux la
question migratoire parce qu'il y a
effectivement des liens entre la lutte
contre l'islamisme radical et
l'évolution des flux migratoires
donc on a beaucoup de sujets sur la
table on a fait aussi beaucoup
d'amendements beaucoup malheureusement
été rejetée et je le regrette parce que
la majorité ne veut pas ce débat est la
peur de ce débat parce que cette
majorité en marche aller mal à l'aise
avec ce projet de loi sur le séparatisme
eh bien nous on va lui dire maintenant
choisissez le chemin la lutte contre
l'islamisme radical c'est d'être une
priorité de tous les jours un combat de
tous les instants et nous devons nous y
attaquer totalement mes skis quelles
différences tamouls il y aura avec le
texte gouvernemental
outre les angles morts la différence
entre ce qui existe dans le texte est ce
que vous avez contre eux proposé que
c'est un contre projet je me refusais
hausse 1,8 ha ha permettez moi de dire
je le présenterai d'un matin mais je
vous en prend juste une montre un
exemple c'est que nous on veut changer
la constitution
le gouvernement veut raisonné à droit
constant
pourquoi on veut changer la constitution
parce que on considère aujourd'hui qu'il
ya trop d'atteinte à la laïcité et que
donc il faut donner de la possibilité
par exemple à un maître d'école un
directeur d'établissement un directeur
d'hôpital d'avoir les moyens et les
outils juridiques d'agir est donc clos
disons c'est l'article qui avait proposé
ailleurs
annie genevard c'est que nul ne peut se
prévaloir de son origine ou de sa
religion pour échapper à la règle
commune ça doit être inscrit dans la
constitution pour contrôler et mieux
sanctionner les atteintes à la liberté
alors la discussion générale a commencé
aujourd'hui plusieurs amendements ont
été jugées irrecevables par le président
de l'assemblée nationale est ce que vous
allez quand même mener la bataille dans
l'hémicycle
oui bien entendu on va la mener de front
dans l'hémicycle d'ailleurs au moment de
cette commission spéciale la semaine
dernière le match il a été entre nous et
la majorité en marche les autres et ans
aux abonnés absents je pense au
rassemblement national on soit très mal
à l'aise je pense
de gauche la réalité c'est quoi c'est
que avec annie genevard eric ciotti eric
diard et tous les députés de la
commission spéciale et les autres
membres du groupe l'est républicain
on est force de proposition mais sur ce
texte comme sur tous les autres textes
vous avez vu sur les retraites
vous avez vues sur beaucoup de sujets à
chaque fois on est combatif respectueux
mais combatif il ya beaucoup
d'amendements jugé irrecevable qui
portait sur le voile notamment marine le
pen elle veut interdire le voile dans
tout l'espace public
est ce que vous vous êtes d'accord avec
cette idée la marine le pen elle ment
aux français parce que interdire le vol
dans tout l'espace public ça n'a
absolument aucun sens ça ne tient pas
juridiquement c'est anticonstitutionnel
et s'est fait reprendre au français des
choses qui nous malheureusement ne
pourront pas être réaliste
nos propositions à nous elles sont
réalistes elles sont concrètes et j'en
ai assez de ces slogans madame le pen
allait jamais présentes à l'assemblée
nationale elle intervient quasi n'en fut
rien elle n'a jamais rien à dire là en
tant que n 1 inscrit alors est très peu
de temps par al nono mer ok mais il ya
d'autres n'ont inscrit que l'on entend
madame ménard par exemple est beaucoup
plus présente donc ce quand on veut on
peut
la réalité aujourd'hui c'est que comme
toujours le front national vie de
slogans nous on est un parti de
gouvernement en responsabilité on doit
faire de la lutte contre israël tandis
qu'alain combat de tous les instants la
différence avec la majorité c'est qu'on
n'est pas aveuglé et c'est que entre les
paroles et les actes
il doit pas y avoir les quarts comme on
a connu entre le discours présidentiel
des mureaux et la réalité de ce texte
qui est très pop
c'est ça la réalité c'est ça notre
combat cette loi jésuite de très
nombreuses réserves de la part des
religions on l'a entendu en commission
en particulier les catholiques ces
religions craignent que l'état
surveillent leur activité avec cette
phrase que vous partager leurs craintes
ou ils ont raison et d'ailleurs ce
seront les deux angles d'attaqué que
nous aurons sur ce projet de loi la
partie je viens d'évoquer de la lutte
contre l'islamisme radical
mais j'aurais pas non plus qu'on oublie
la partie sur les libertés vous savez la
droite
on oublie trop souvent qu'on est le
parti des libertés et bien sûr qu'il ya
une inquiétude parce que la loi de 1905
c'est une loi de liberté parce que la
liberté de culte c'est une liberté
fondamentale
parce que la liberté d'enseignement elle
ne peut pas être bradée et comme moi je
crois en ses libertés et que c'est pas
parce que il ya certains individus qui
utilisent cette liberté pour la dévoyer
que tout le monde doit être sanctionné
ou contrôlés sur le même plan
en train de casser par exemple la loi de
1905 sur la séparation de l'église et de
l'état
je trouve que sur certains aspects en
ambre astro et on est très mal exemple
l'instruction en famille et je pense que
là dessus on doit corriger les champs va
y revenir mais juste sur la loi de 1905
vous disais est ce que vous avez
l'impression que c'est ça enterre un peu
la loi de 1905 et la loi favorable sur
la laïcité en france aujourd'hui je
dirais pas que ça l'inter mais je trouve
que l'essence de cette loi 1905
c'est une loi de liberté et je voudrais
pas que l'on transforme une loi de
liberté en une loi liberticide
c'est un enjeu pour nous est ce que pour
éviter cet écueil il aurait fallu un
texte qui vise plus précisément
l'islamisme radical bouille très
clairement oui
d'ailleurs nous nous voulons lutter
contre l'islamisme radical
d'ailleurs je suis frappé par ce
changement c'est matic même s'ils
avaient posé des concerts des problèmes
constitutionnels t elle dit aujourd'hui
le goudron mais on peut organiser les
choses
utilisez des tas d'or l'état de droit
soit pas être un obstacle ça va être un
allié un atout quand on lutte contre
celles et ceux qui veulent combattre à
mort la république française c'est ça la
réalité est donc là dessus moi je dis
très clairement que quand on passe d'un
projet de loi sur la lutte contre
l'islamisme radical
un projet de loi que de la lutte contre
le séparatisme un projet de loi qui
renforce les principes républicains
vous avez compris que c'est un projet de
loi de renom j'ai pour la gauche y avait
un risque de stigmatiser les musulmans
vous ne pensez pas que ça le vrai nom en
lançant et moi je reprends les sens
discours numéro laissant discours du
bureau c'est de faire la distinction
entre le musulman qui respectent les
lois de la république
il y en a beaucoup et vous savez eux ils
nous disent mais lutter contre
l'islamisme radical
parce que nous aussi on en a assez
d'être montrés du doigt à cause de cette
poignée fait pour vous laisser messieurs
radical s'est passé c'est au delà de la
religion c'est vrai n'a presque plus
rien à voir et leur religion mais c'est
aussi un objet politique tout le monde
le sait c'est aussi aller sur un terrain
politique
c'est mettre à mal tout simplement nos
principes républicains et n'oubliez pas
que ce texte il a été construit quand
même dans la salle dans le contexte de
l'assassinât du professeur sam le pâtis
vous perdriez d'instruction à domicile
brigitte oui il y aura des dérogations
pour l'instruction à domicile qui sera
beaucoup plus encadré est ce que c'est
un bon moyen de lutter quand même contre
les enseignements coraniques radicaux
qui sont délivrés à la maison et pour
être
beaucoup d'interrogations ce sujet la
vérité c'est que l'instruction en
famille c'est soixante mille personnes
et que vous avez pas 60000 radicaliser
islamistes vous avez des femmes et des
hommes sont à notre porte skis et 12
millions d'élèves en france
oui mais ça fait rien non mais vous
voyez c'était représente je comprends
tout à fait c'est pour sa musique ce
n'est pas le coeur du texte mais que
c'est un débat important parce que l'on
touche à la liberté d'enseignement ce
que nous disons nous tout simplement
c'est de dire ne jetons pas le bébé avec
l'eau du bain il faut renforcer les
contrôles renforcés les sanctions donner
des moyens budgétaires pour faire des
contrôles plus fort de l'instruction en
famille mais gardons cette liberté et
puis je vais même aller plus loin
vous avez aujourd'hui des enfants qui
sont scolarisés et ce qui n'empêche pas
que le vendredi soir ou le week end is
nigh ensuite suivre des cours dans les
écoles coraniques donc la non scolarisés
la scolarisation n'est pas non plus un
gage d'assurance face à lille face au
fait de nos radicalisation de ces
enfants donc pour nous l'enjeu il est
global et attention quand même ne pas
jeter le bébé avec l'eau du bain un
autre aspect ya plein d'aspects dans
cette loi sur le renforcement des prix
et des principes républicains et
notamment la loi contre pour lutter
comme enfin l'aspect lutte contre la
haine en ligne c'était la condition
doivent y aille à l'époque vous aviez
voté contre elle a finalement été cassée
pour cause de constitutionnalité est ce
que la nouvelle rédaction de l'article
dans ce projet de loi contre les
principes pour défend des principes
républicains eh bien il pourrait vous
faire changer d'avis et est ce que le
niveau qu'on vient finalement c'est une
meilleure rédaction nous avions voté
contre pour une raison très simple c'est
qu'on donnait en fait la compétence et
le pouvoir aux gars fin de sanctionner
pour nous ça c'est pas acceptable c'est
l'autorité de régulation ça ne peut pas
être les gaffes à ça doit être l'état
qui doit avoir cette responsabilité là
la régulation sur internet oui parce
qu'il y en a assez de l'outrance y en a
assez de de ces comportements qui sont
totalement inadmissibles derrière des
comptes anonymes donc moi je suis aussi
favorable à la levée de l'anonymat sur
internet
mais je le dis aussi n'oublions pas
qu'internet est aussi un formidable
espace de liberté qui doit vivre surtout
pour mener campagne électorale oui mais
pas seulement c'est vrai
mais qui doit foisonner et là aussi on
doit trouver un bel équilibre qui
n'existait pas dans la loi mais donc là
ça peut vous convenir je trouve que la
rédaction et meilleur donc on aura un
certain nombre d'amendements on verra en
fonction de nos amendements qu'ils en
donnent une dernière question non vous
faisiez 6 merci en tout cas c'est
brigitte étape d'être venu sur le
plateau deux auditions publiques et
rendez vous lundi prochain
évidemment on va parler du bureau de la
sécurité sera encore un autre chantier
qui a été lancée aujourd'hui cinq mois
de concertation prévue pour se pencher
sur le métier de policier
les syndicats demandent plus de moyens
une meilleure reconnaissance aussi de la
profession
la question est de savoir si parce que
ça doit aboutir normalement à une loi
d'ici la fin du quinquennat
est ce que vous y croyez non non je n'y
crois pas parce que bull sait que péter
l'objectif ça devrait être une loi de
programmation sur la sécurité qui dit
votre programmation d'une loi sur
plusieurs années et ça vous a pas
échappé qui reste malheureusement
quelques mois d'ici l'élection
présidentielle ce sera un hors-jeu 2000
reste d'affichage c'est la communication
et ça serait d'un enjeu pour 2022 alors
il ya eu parce que ça montre aussi à la
suite ça arrive à la suite aussi des
débats sur les violences policières
quand il y à des dérives de policier
c'est l'igpn c'est à dire la police des
polices qui intervient et qui disent il
doit y avoir sanction si c'est si un
policier s'est mal comporté ou pas c'est
à dire un système à l'intérieur même de
la police est-ce qu'il faut changer ce
système ou réformés simplement l'igpn
moi je pense qu'on peut le faire évoluer
mais je veux pas non plus jeter
l'opprobre sur les gp est née gpn fait
son travail c'est pas parce que vous
êtes dans un système interne qui ont
fait pas un travail sérieux indépendant
et libre
la réalité aussi c'est que les violences
policières elle existe il y en a il faut
les sanctionner
mais elles sont sans commune mesure avec
les violences que les policiers
subissent au quotidien et qui sont
totalement intolérable et inadmissible
l'igpn reste le bon outil pour vous ça
reste un outil on peut l'améliorer avec
un nouveau l'améliorer vous habiterez
c'est moi je suis faudra losc là dessus
à ce qu'on puisse y travaillent et bien
entendu au passage on a parlé de la loi
sur les principes républicains et puis
on parle là du baudet sécurité derrière
tout ça il ya un homme qui s'appelle
gérald darmanin mise de l'intérieur
c'est lui qui est devant au devant de
tous et de tous ces chantiers qui vient
de vos rangs à l'origine est ce que
c'est un bon mise l'intérieur il est
meilleur que christophe castaner il a
une certaine volonté
d'action mais il est prisonnier d'une
majorité de la république en marche qui
ne veut que ne rien ne change
qui veut que le status quo et qui en
fait ne voulait pas de ce territoire il
est meilleur que christophe castaner
d'abord parce que il défend ses
policiers et quand on minimise
l'intérieur on doit déjà défendre ses
policiers si j'en entends ce que n'a pas
fait le miz intérieur de l'époque mais
c'est pas suffisant et aujourd'hui
permettez moi de vous dire que un
bourreau de la sécurité sont un
accompagnement d'une réforme pénale ça
n'aura aucun impact
ça n'aura aucune réalité concrète pour
les français et donc beaucoup
d'artifices beaucoup de huitième
communication mais là encore peu de
réalisations et d'actes alors damien
abad en tant que président du groupe
l'est républicain
les républiques à la nationale vous avez
un rôle important pour les républicains
pour le parti des républicains on va en
parler avec il triomphe arrive
bonsoir francis au figaro qui étaient
avec nous comme tous les lundis soirs
alors je voudrais on regarde aujourd'hui
beaucoup ce qui se passe aux
républicains les débats les débats
internes aussi et on s'aperçoit que
finalement au fil des interviews des
écrits les prises de position il ya
peut-être deux lignes dans ce parti une
ligne que vous incarnez qui est une
ligne plutôt libérale et d'ailleurs je
rappelle que vous étiez dans l'équipe de
campagne de bruno le maire pendant la
campagne des primaires de 2016-2017
et puis notre ligne qui revient qui plus
étatiste qui prônent par exemple le
revenu universel le rsa pour les jeunes
qui est défendu par des jeunes
guillaume pelletier dont pas que vous
soyez pas jeune guillaume pelletier et
aurélien pradié est ce que ces lignes
sont vraiment compatible oui à condition
de ne pas surjouer nos différences mais
à condition aussi d'avoir un vrai débat
entre nous parce qu'on doit trancher ce
débat économique et centrale moi je
croyais pas tranché encore aujourd'hui
non moi je crois aux libertés
je crois à la liberté d'entreprendre je
crois que la droite soit le parti la
culture du risque que c'est là le parti
du courage de l'audace
je crois la baisse des charges sur les
entreprises je crois à l'accompagnement
individuel je crois tous ces sujets là
on vient de parler sur le séparatisme je
pense que la question des libertés allée
centrale aussi là dessus ça ne veut pas
dire que je suis contre tout
accompagnement social bien au contraire
mais je ne suis pas sûr que le chemin de
la droite ça soit celui du revenu
vers celle pour tous est celui du rsa
pour les jeunes non je crois que le
chemin de la droite c'est celui de
l'ascenseur social celui de la
méritocratie celui du travail et je
crois qu'on peut se retrouver là dessus
par contre là où tout le monde a raison
c'est qu'on peut pas faire comme s'il
n'y avait pas eu de crise sanitaire
et moi je suis par exemple favorable à
ce que sur certains secteurs clés
stratégiques comme la santé mais pas
seulement
il ya une souveraineté économique qui
puisse exercer au niveau national comme
au niveau européen d'ailleurs mais cette
souveraineté économique elle est tout à
fait compatible avec une économie
sociale de marché
alors je vous sais assez proche de zahia
bertrand idées ou xavier bertrand lui
dans ce paysage là parce que il a un
discours qui est quand même un discours
assez social on va dire mais vous vous
êtes proche de lui quand même oui parce
que d'abord il est à droite la question
d'autorité de sécurité et régalienne il
est clairement de droite
ensuite il a raison d'avoir cette fibre
sociale et humaniste elle est
fondamentale est ce qu'aujourd'hui faut
pas oublier qu'il ya beaucoup de jeunes
qui tombent dans la pauvreté ça c'est
une réalité il ya beaucoup de jeunes qui
sont sans emploi
il ya de la précarité dans notre pays et
donc sur tous ces sujets là il a montré
d'ailleurs son savoir-faire en région
dans une région difficile dans les hauts
de france mais nous nous trompons pas
vous avez bertrand il est pas en train
de créer une alliance avec arnaud
montebourg
xavier bertrand il est là simplement
pour dire aux françaises et aux français
moi je veux un contact direct avec vous
je veux dépasser les seules clivage
partisan je suis de droite je viens de
la droite ça vous êtes sûrs d'une chose
at il a tendu la main à nos mondes boas
jean pierre chevènement parce que il l'a
pas fait la réalité c'est que c'est
surtout arnaud montebourg qui a tendu la
main à xavier bertrand et à la droite
peut-être parce que lui-même est en
perdition dans son propre parti
politique mais qui a été acceptée et moi
moi je n'en mets moi je n'oublie pas que
monsieur montebourg
il a quitté un gouvernement de gauche
parce qu'il ne trouvait pas assez à
gauche et je n'oublie pas non plus le
combat de monsieur montebourg face à
jacques chirac
il ya peut-être des choses je dis pas
que tout est à jeter mais je ne me
reconnais pas dans cet homme-là ni dans
cette politique qu'il a menée qui l'a
conduite et je pense que nos électeurs
ils ont besoin de ça on sent chez
bertrand qui est l'homme qui aujourd'hui
occupe beaucoup le devant de la scène
dans notre parti enfin il pas de votre
parti d'ailleurs mais à droite
on sent qu'il a changé de ton il était
très offensif très critique vis-à-vis du
gouvernement et puis là eh bien on a
l'impression qu'il a décidé de jouer
différemment le la faire non je crois
qu'en fait ça dépend des circonstances
pourquoi il a eu un ton offensif et
critiques au moment des au début de
cette année ce qui est le cas de bruno
retailleau syrie traître et ils ont
raison mais pourquoi parce que
honnêtement cette lenteur vaccinale du
début était absolument inadmissible on a
vu en france toute la bureaucratie qui
nous a étouffés qui empêchait de faire
une politique de vaccination au concours
de l'eurovision des vaccins on était les
derniers les choses ont été corrigés sur
la partie logistique maintenant il
manque des doses à notre sujet et sur la
partie logistique aujourd'hui on est
capable de mettre des centres de
vaccination partout en france et je peux
vous dire une chose c'est que je pense
que notre coup de gueule a été utile et
salvateur puisque d'ailleurs des
médecins des professions médicales l'ont
fait également est donc xavier bertrand
il est comme tout le monde quand il y
est dit les choses bien il le dit quand
les choses ne vieillit pas et puis enfin
on est dans un moment de crise sanitaire
et je ne crois pas à la politique
politicienne ni à la critique
systématique et stérile et je sais que
l'édifice sion sont difficiles à prendre
et donc il faut un peu de modestie et un
peu d'humilité par ces temps là d'accord
alors l'élection présidentielle approche
néanmoins il ya beaucoup de leurs on
dira de l'ambition dans votre parti
bono retailleau michel barnier et à
l'extérieur on parle de xavier bertrand
parle aussi de valérie pécresse et le
président du sénat qui est des
républicains avait dit on va essayer de
trouver un système de départage entre
tous ces supposées ou présumés pardon
candidat est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec ce système de départage qui ne
ressemblerait pas à une primaire ouverte
comme en 2000 comme la dernière fois non
je ne crois pas au yalta du départage je
crois au candidat naturel
je crois à la kpc d'arles droit de se
rassembler derrière une femme ou un
homme qui sera devant qui montrera aux
français ses atouts ses compétences
devant ou dans les sondages mais déjà
mais amy rhodia des sondages il ya un
certain nombre de d'éléments qu'on
pourra voir c'est pourquoi je crois pas
se départagent parce que je crois que ça
va nous enfermer dans un système de
l'entre- soit qui sera des années
lumières des attentes des français qui
va nous couper de leurs attentes dans un
moment de crise sanitaire et économique
majeure donc là dessus vous attendez des
désaccords avec le président du sénat
gérard larcher
moi je dis et je sais ce que gérard
larcher et d'ailleurs et c'est à son
mérite de vouloir essayer de rassembler
de pouvoir jouer collectif de vouloir
essayer de trouver une solution
et moi je salue ce travail là parce que
gérard larcher c'est quelqu'un qui
rassemble dans notre famille politique
et je dis simplement que d'un système de
départage fait sur un coin de table
entre nous j'y crois pas vous n'y croyez
pas ça il faut qu'il y ait quelqu'un qui
émerge votre choix vous ses alliés
bertrand c'est écoutez je ne fais pas de
langue de bois vous le savez j'ai dit
mon affinité mon affection et puis
surtout le fait que je pense qu'il peut
incarner la droite qui gagne aujourd'hui
on a besoin de quelqu'un qui incarne la
droite qui gagne xavier bertrand a gagné
dans une région de france face à madame
le pen dans un contexte extrêmement
difficile maintenant il est trop tôt on
verra d'abord il faut déjà qu'il soit
candidat
ensuite il y aura peut-être des
élections départementales et régionales
en tout cas je le souhaite au printemps
enfin donc il faudra voir aussi qu'elle
sera la carte politique à ce moment là
et par les obstacles par obstacles et
préparons les choses et moi ce que je
souhaite c'est aussi qu'une dynamique
qui s'instaure autour d'un candidat pour
qu'on puisse tout simplement avoir et
défendre nos couleurs élections prénom
ida doit être connue qu'en après les
élections régionales c'est ce qu'a dit
christian jacob dont côté ou après cet
été ou après l'été si les élections
régionales ont lieu conformément à ce
qui est indiqué c'est à dire au moins de
manière quasi mettons nous dans un
scénario qui va pas vous plaire mais
après tout imaginer que les soldats
soient très mauvais pour le candidat de
la droite on voit qu'ils sont très
mauvais pour les candidats de la gauche
républicaine la gauche parties se sont
entendues au logist même la france
insoumise et que on se dirige vers un un
combat où nous revanche entre madame le
pen et monsieur macron est-ce que alors
que les sondages disent que madame le
pen peut gagner
est ce qu'elle peut gagner madame le pen
je ne le souhaite pas je n'en sais rien
mais ça montre quoi ça montre que
emmanuel macron n'est plus le rempart
face au front national
si madame le pen est en capacité de
faire 48 aujourd'hui dans les sondages
s'en montre qu'aujourd'hui un sondage
d'argent que je suis tanné c'est pour ça
nous verrons soyons à 14 euros mais
quatre premiers mois nous ressentons
tous malgré tout sur le terrain une
montée de rassemblement national
et donc ce que je dis simplement
aujourd'hui c'est que c'est très
dangereux de vouloir faire un match
binaire entre le prix dans la nuit
certains et le rassemblement leurs
suggestions mais il ya la troisième
partie de la gestion de la question
c'est y pas de briller français sur
trois n'ont justement un brièvement si
c'était le cas
est ce que pour que madame le pen ne
gagne pas est ce que vous pourriez vous
désister pour monsieur macron qui somme
toute ne fait pas une politique
particulièrement de gauche vous rendez
compte on est à 1 10 mois de l'élection
présidentielle
quatorze mois et maintenant se dire déjà
d'entrée on va commencer le match en
disant on va se désister non la réalité
n'est pas là à la réalité c'est qu'on y
va pour gagner et si moi je souhaite que
quelqu'un comme xavier bertrand puisse
porter nos couleurs c'est justement pour
incarner la droite qui gagne c'est
justement pour cette question là ne se
pose pas et c'est pour bousculer l'ordre
préétabli deuxième tour merci
merci pour des professionnels des
stations de ski ont bloqué l'autoroute
près du tunnel de fréjus aujourd'hui
quelque temps pour attirer là aussi
après les restaurateurs l'attention du
gouvernement sur leur sort c'est un
sujet que vous connaissez bien
alors on vient d'apprendre parce que
jean castex recevait les prochaines à
tout à l'heure qu'il n'y aura pas de
réouverture des stations de ski
pendant tout le mois de février c'est
une confirmation et que les commerces de
matériel de ski et les activités annexes
seront pris en charge par les aides de
l'état des pertes selon les
professionnels du ski et de ce tout ce
secteur pourrait s'élever entre 9 et 10
milliards pour toute une saison
chiffre contesté par le gouvernement
est-ce que quoi qu'il en soit le prix
j'allais dire il faut une prise en
charge à 100 %
oui c'est terrible c'est terrible pour
la montagne française c'est une année
blanche sans jeu de mots est aujourd'hui
beaucoup ne s'en relèveront pas
les vendeurs de matériel de ski ce
qu'ils font les remontées mécaniques
tout le travail saisonnier
c'est une économie je voudrais
simplement dire aux français que la
montagne le ski c'est pas simplement
quelque chose d'élitiste qui fait de
l'entretoit est minoritaire à 8 % des
français le théâtre hall avantage mais
c'est une économie celles et ceux qui
vivent en savoie haute savoie dans notre
département de l'ain et qui vivent de
l'économie de montagne sonico mis à part
entière donc il faut l'accompagner
moi je demande un plan marshall pour la
montagne avec laurent wauquiez à la
région auvergne rhône-alpes
nous oeuvrons pour obtenir justement ces
aides économiques indispensables pour
éviter tous ces pros plus en plus de la
prise en charge à 100% voulez lire où il
faut qu'il y ait une prise en charge à
100% ça comme il faut aussi qu'on ait
une perspective parce que ça sera dur de
remonter sur le cheval demain et après
demain on sait déjà que c'est difficile
pour les stations de moyenne montagne
moi je suis aussi dans l'un il ya des
plans d'hotonnes ya le plateau
d'hauteville c'est déjà difficile
soutien des collectivités ne mendie pas
de d'ouverture des remontées mécaniques
pour le mois de février peut-être même
en avril on verra ça mais ça s'est un
peu plus tard pour vous une ouverture
des stations de ski se serait
envisageable
non soyons sérieux honnêtement
aujourd'hui vu le contexte sanitaire
actuelle malheureusement tout le monde a
compris qu'on prépare moi j'ai fait une
proposition
c'était qu'on puisse faire une ouverture
de proximité locale le modèle autrichien
avec une attestation dans un rayon de
100 kilomètres pour pouvoir faire du ski
et la journée parce que le problème
c'est pas sur la remontée mécanique
le problème c'est le brassage de
population que vous avez
dans une commune qui passe de 2001
minami puis les files d'attentes tout le
monde sait que lutine damien abad il est
où maintenant d'accueillir vos collègues
parlementaires pour débattre bonsoir
erwan balanant bonsoir vous êtes député
modem du finistère et vous allez
débattre avec damien abad sur différents
sujets que vous avez choisi parce que
c'est la formule ce sont les
parlementaires qui choisissent leur
sujet et pierre ouzeau l'ias bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes sénateur pcf des
hauts-de-seine et lui dans un
département de droite mais voilà le pcf
et réussi à faire élire sénateur avec
les divisions de la droite je vous dis
pas ce que ça raconte quelque chose ça
raconte quelque chose pour commencer une
première question des rois de bananes en
vouliez parler vous de la
proportionnelle oui je voulais poser une
question à damien abad
l'ancien centriste qu'il a été très
proche de ma famille politique à un
moment donné je crois même avoir vu
qu'il a même été défenseur de la
proportionnelle on voit aujourd'hui que
la proportionnelle s'impose dans le
débat public les français sont magiques
majoritairement pour pour l'élection des
députés pour l'élection des députés
évidemment on voit que souvent vauban
nous font le reproche à la majorité
d'être trop majoritaire et d'avoir une
position dominante et je voulais savoir
dans quelle mesure il avait changé sur
la proportionnelle et pourquoi la
proportionnelle ne pourrait pas être cet
élément qui redonne du pouvoir au
parlement qui rôdent mais de la
diversité dans notre dans notre débat
public politique
donc voilà la question damien abad
pourquoi n'êtes vous plus pour la
proportionnelle
on amorce c'est un sujet important
difficile les qui mérite une certaine
attention et réflexion
ça fait 40 ans qu'on en parle oui mais
bien sûr donc c'est que ça doit vraiment
être un sujet difficile et je vais vous
dire pourquoi
pour deux raisons j'y crois pas la
première c'est je pense qu'aujourd'hui
le lien entre les députés et les
territoires et les français se distend
de plus en plus qui a une crise de
confiance politique qui existe
aujourd'hui qui peut être n'était pas
aussi forte ya dix ans et que ma crainte
c'est que si demain on fait un système
proportionnel ça veut dire quoi
c'est un système c'est les partis
politiques qu'ils choisissent
quand vous faites la proportionnelle
c'est le parti qui vous dit vous êtes
numéro un le numéro deux et numéro trois
c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne chez
aux élections régionales on les
élections européennes
quand vous êtes élu député vous êtes est
lui aussi au scrutin uninominal sur
votre nom bien sûr qu'il ya un impact
national
mais il ya aussi en est pas de moi vous
savez j'ai été élu pas grâce à telle ou
telle étiquette c'est parce qu'on est
les gens me connaissaient et par
l'impact qu'on a sur le terrain je crois
cet ancrage territorial et la deuxième
raison c'est que franchement dans cette
période de crise sanitaire et économique
majeure je crois et permettez moi de
vous le dire que ce sujet il est
accessoire est secondaire pour les
france alors je veux dire au moins deux
chaussures sur l'ancrage local je pense
plutôt tout le contraire salaire s'il ya
une défiance vis-à-vis du parlement de
nos citoyens c'est pas parce qu'il sent
pas que le député est issu de chez eux
il est tout de toute façon issu d'un
territoire ce qu'ils on sait que ils ont
l'impression de ne pas être représenté
aujourd'hui vous avez des courants
politiques français est important qu'on
les aime qu'on les aime pas qu'ils n'ont
pas de deux députés je pense aux
écologistes
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas des députés
écologistes et je pense évidemment à
marine le pen est au rassemblement ce
rassemblement national et je pense que
c'est ça qui fait la rupture avec les
français c'est le premier point à la
fois promis à première votre jeu où il
pensait aussi au parti qu ai je pensé
aux parties commis c'est d'ailleurs
assurée sans doute été élu grâce à la
proportionnelle c'est évident bien la
preuve que celle là on s'en doute un bon
score pour rebondir sur la question qui
est importante sur la question de ses
pas le moment
si c'est toujours le moment pour mettre
plus de démocratie dans un pays à l'aube
franchement si la question de la crise
de confiance entre le politique et les
français se résumer à un mode de scrutin
à la proportionnelle ça se saurait par
contre là où je vous rejoins c'est qu'il
faut renforcer les droits du parlement
ils font un parlement plus fort et ça je
pense qu'on partage ça ensemble
c'est que aujourd'hui on a perdu notre
culture parlementaire en france et c'est
pas que ce gouvernement sur usenet
ça fait longtemps que ça dure et moi je
souhaite qu'on a un vrai contrepoids un
parlement plus fort c'est un parlement
qui rendent et comme vous avez dit tout
à l'heure en démarrant que c'était le
choix des parlementaires les sujets mais
voilà une bonne nouvelle si c'était plus
souvent le cas à l'assemblée nationale
ça serait bien donc il faut renforcer
les droits du parlement
franchement je vais là sur sa sur la
proportionnelle
erwan balanant que le fait que des
courants de pensée qui n'est pas de
représentants par rapport à leur poids
oui mais ça c'est vrai mais je l'entends
mai mais n'oublions pas dans la colonne
sélection s'il ya des élections
régionales il ya des élections
européennes dans lequel il ya une
représentation proportionnelle je
rappelle aussi que la vème république
elle a été fait pour créer ce qu'on
appelle le fait majoritaire parce qu'
est-ce qu'on veut moi je veux pas
retourner à la ivème république et au
système des partis dans lequel n'y a pas
de majorité
pas de décisions qui sont prises ne
voulait pas de la majorité bayrou défend
des majorités de progrès pas de
progresser mais c'est pas une question
pourquoi des majorités de projets c'est
pas une dose de proportionnelle
ce qu'ils proposent c'est un scrutin
totalement la programmation c'est pas du
tout emballé tout ce qu'on prend son
envol il alerte on aura tous les
parlements des moyens moins 50% mais au
moins tu as bien damien 50% vous
farouche défenseur du parlement et je le
sais un parlement qui serait vraiment
représentatifs et ça je suis d'accord
aurait beaucoup plus de pouvoir qu'un
parlement qui comme aujourd'hui et je
peux vous le dire en toute liberté je
suis dans la majorité est
majoritairement d'un parti et on a aussi
effectivement tous les pouvoirs il
retrouvera juan que c'est que c'est vrai
et moi je partage cette analyse là mais
je croyais pas aussi que c'est lié à la
conjonction des de l'élection
présidentielle élections législatives
ces élections législatives trois
semaines après l'élection présidentielle
forcément comment ils ont été élus les
députés en marche beaucoup c'est parce
qu'ils avaient la photo des manuels
macron sur leurs tracts c'est ça la
réalité alors super du septennat c'est
vous oui mais vous avez vu que la
proposition de xavier bertrand sur
certaines ombres développe c'est nous
aussi
pierrot julias vouliez parler de laïcité
puisqu'on lui ok tout à l'heure les
inquiétudes des régions mais voulait
aller plus loin parce que vous vous
dites c'est aussi une question de
liberté de conscience
bien sûr mais je j'ai compris en vous
écoutant chers collègues députés que
nous étions d'accord voilà et je m'en
félicite
c'est d'abord sur l'aï dit c'est une loi
liberticide c'est une c'est une loi qui
va permettre à l'état 2
de rentrer dans le fonctionnement des
religions comme jamais depuis 1905 et je
cite le nonce apostolique à paris je
suis ambassadeur du vatican vent je suis
sénateur communiste et athée et donc
vous voyez là il n'y a pas de conflit
d'intérêt je le cite un je crains que le
projet de loi n'introduise une inflexion
sécuritaire dans l'économie générale du
régime de séparation issu de la loi de
je crois que nous en sommes là et cette
loi vous l'avez lu aussi très justement
l attaque d'autres libertés qui sont
fondamentales et qui fonde notre
république c'est la liberté d'expression
notamment la liberté de la presse que
que vous représentez et aussi la liberté
d'association avec la loi de 1901
donc là avec cette loi on a un condensé
de toutes les attaques liberticide de ce
gouvernement depuis quatre ans est ce
que c'est d'être des attaques des
artistes qui vont aussi loin que ça il
ya des choses sur lesquelles on converge
est pas tout et pas tous pas tout parce
que nous on veut aussi donner tous les
moyens les outils pour lutter contre
l'islamisme radical
et là-dessus pas d'angélisme il nous
faut des actes concrets et il nous faut
des moyens
ce projet ne va pas assez loin 62 points
on propose d'aller plus loin un des
propositions très concrètes que l'on
détaillera prochainement mais mais mais
au-delà de ça là où je vous rejoins
c'est que qui embrasse trop être un mal
et que don parfois sur certains sujets
j'ai dit tout à l'heure sur la liberté
d'enseignement mais pas seulement il ya
d'autres sujets aussi sur lesquels
effectivement cette loi elle a un
potentiel liberticide réel et nous on
sera vigilant sur les deux aspects mais
vous vous êtes sur des points précis
pire vous dire s'il va beaucoup plus
loin il dit liberté d'expression liberté
de la presse etc
oui non mais nous on est autour de la
loi via on a voté contre ensemble nous
ça va changer peut-être baissé le rideau
mais je sais que la droite c'est
important parce que c'est un débat
important je moi je défends l'idée que
nous sommes le parti des libertés et là
dessus on pousse trop jeune et
d'ailleurs j'ai souvenir aussi à
l'époque où françois bayrou avait sept
ce sentiment là donc il ya des choses je
trouve qu'il ya des choses qui sont mal
adaptés dans ce texte
mais notre différence c'est que par
contre moi je souhaite voilà très
clairement par exemple je suis pas sûr
vous soyez pour que on
la lutte contre l'immigration dans ce
texte sur le projet de loi séparatisme
ou la question de la radicalisation des
prix dans les prisons ou dans les airs
cité où la question du voile
selah sue où on pourra aussi avoir je
crois des divergences vous veillez un
certain nombre de points de combat sur
lequel on peut ce que moi je vois moi je
vois surtout une grosse divergence qui
est à l'international l'islamisme
radical il est religion d'état
dans plusieurs pays entre le wahhabisme
en vallis mcef ici il n'ya pas beaucoup
de différence
or nous continuons à travailler avec ces
états comme si de rien n'était ces mêmes
aujourd'hui nos premiers clients en
armement donc il faudrait avoir un peu
de cohérence et dénoncer l'islamisme
radical à la fois en france mais aussi
quand il est religion d'état et dans le
domaine des affaires
d'où lui vient son jeu d'où l'enjeu de
l'interdiction faisait pas entendu la
cellule en mai d'où l'enjeu de
l'interdiction comme de certains
financements on l'a expliqué certains
financements internationaux qui sont
faits pour aller financer tel ou tel
lieu de culte et autres etc
c'est une règle à l'assumer la suit le
projet de loi d'un certain nombre de
propositions écouter on peut pas
continuer à vendre oui mais des rafales
à un état dont la religion de l'état et
le salafisme c'est ce que je dis sans
vous êtes d'accord éclairer là moi je
suis très clair le soleil ne l'est pas
claires la sicile sur la fin vous n'êtes
pas clair est-ce qu'on vend des avions
l'arabie saoudite mais vous savez sur
l'arabie saoudite je sais pas sûr
d'ailleurs que ce soit le pays qui
déstabilise le plus la zone mais on
pourrait en débattre et ça nous
renverrait sur des considérations
internationales sont en fait le plus le
plus grand projet litis mans france sans
doute pas seulement non c'est ça aussi
je suis acteur à vis à vis il vous le
savez parce qu'on pourrait parler
d'autres pays dont on connaît bien le
prosélytisme religieux qui est réel
aujourd'hui qu'en sera-t-il pays avec
beaucoup lui-même des tâches et la
turquie par exemple les sites et vous
serez très clairement on voit bien d'où
l'intérêt de former mieux nos immeubles
et aussi d'avoir des aumôniers en prison
pour accompagner et mieux accompagner
cet islam de france
alors vos corps comme vous avait taclé
un peu erwan balanant via françois
bayrou il est loyal et non non je crois
qu'il est me tacler mais même moi je
n'en sais tu es plutôt répondre sur sur
cette idée là ce chèque est soudain sans
arrêt
secoué d'une loi liberticide et que nous
serions toujours dans des mesures
liberticides non c'est pas vrai on peut
pas dire que ce texte liberticide
ce texte va mettre un certain nombre de
garanties il ne touche pas à la loi de
1901 il touche à la loi de 1905 mais en
lui donnant en s'adaptant à la réalité
de notre monde de notre monde de la
sociologie de notre pays et je crois pas
du tout qu'il soit liberticide il va
clarifier un certain nombre de choses il
va permettre à chacun des cultes de
s'exprimer d'être j'avais j'allais
j'allais dire un mot qui est pas d'être
carré sur ses comptes aussi par rapport
à ces financements extérieurs et et puis
tout ça dans la liberté de la conscience
réaffirmé sur ce texte 10 900 wii major
jean j'entends bien il y avait quelque
chose de fondamental à faire c'était moi
je sus séparatiste c'est à dire que je
défends la séparation absolue de
l'église et de l'état
et vous voulez changer la constitution
je suis d'accord et je souhaite que dans
la constitution il y est on introduisent
l'article 1 et l'article 2 de la loi
1905 c'est à dire que sur le tout le
territoire national
il n'y ait pas deux financement des
cultes par l'état voilà là je pense
qu'on sera pas d'accord non et est ce
que vous êtes d'accord parce que nous on
propose de renforcer la laïcité dans la
constitution et de dire que nul ne peut
se prévaloir de son origine ou de sa
religion pour général de comines sinon
le cas et vous le savez mais si cela je
reste prudent aujourd'hui ce feu m quand
vous êtes directeur d'hôpital
quand vous êtes directeur d'entreprise
quand vous êtes maître d'école quand
vous êtes maître nageur et que vous êtes
face à des atteintes très concrète à la
laïcité c'est très compliqué pour agir
sur le terrain c'est très compliqué pour
faire réguler l'état de droit c'est ça
la réalité la tour news est ce on doit
mieux armé l'état de la droite doit être
un allié et non pas un obstacle à la
halle jean tandis qu'en guyane et vous
avez même pas la loi de 1905 vous savez
la loi de 1905 ne s'applique pas en
guyane la guyane est régie par
l'ordonnancé de 1828 qui fait de la
religion catholique la religion de
l'état
vous croyez pas que c'est un archaïsme
qu'il faudrait supprimer et en profitent
et là maintenant mais peut-être sur la
gueule mais vous savez vous avez aussi
des régimes qui fonctionne bien le droit
alsace aux mosellans il propose un
certain nombre de choses intéressantes
nous coûte cher
oui mais quand
qu'on crée par exemple une école
nationale des aumôniers à côté de
strasbourg je trouve que c'était quelque
chose d'intéressant et qui nous montrent
autre chose à parler de décentralisation
parce que vous voulez parler de ça oui
j'avais une deuxième question sur sur
sur un paradoxe un paradoxe de votre
famille républicaine et un paradoxe
d'ailleurs de l'organisation de notre
pays de manière un peu plus générale je
vous ai écouté tout à l'heure et l
instant encore vous vous avez beaucoup
parlé d'état de droit de souveraineté
économique de pouvoir régalien et on
semble dans votre famille politique
c'est quelque chose d'assez important et
à vous observer tous les mardis sur les
bancs de l'assemblée nationale
je n'ai et à observer la vie politique
aussi général je j'entends souvent je
vous entend souvent dire
et pendant cette crise il faut laisser
les territoires il faut il faut donner
plus de pouvoir aux territoires et jeu
et j'aimerais avoir votre avis sur ce
paradoxe des républicains qui n'a jamais
vraiment tranché cette idée d' entre le
le pouvoir régalien et ce qui me semble
mois centriste breton extrêmement
important la décentralisation et la
confiance qu'on doit donner aux
territoires
comment vous damien abad encore une fois
ancien centriste vous vous positionnez
par les bretons par rapport à vos
collègues républicains qui sont sur
cette idée de que le pouvoir fait tout
et qui sont très loin d'une idée
girondine c'est pas un paradoxe c'est
simplement un équilibre entre ce que
doit faire l'êta est ce que doivent
faire les collectivités locales la
décentralisation
très concrètement moi je suis pour un
état stratège recentrer sur ses
fonctions régaliennes pour moi l'état
c'est l'armée la justice la police et
les secteurs stratégiques clés en
matière économique comme les cités tout
à l'heure sur la question de la santé la
santé aussi par exemple pourquoi tous
les cols d'une région lui s'occupe de
santé oui mais mais pour compenser ce
que les lacs les manques de l'état non
je ne crois pas moi la cie quand on a
créé des mains s'approprier démarre
quand on a acheté des masques quand on a
des effets des politiques de terry c'est
parce qu'elle est là et on avait dans
ses politiques de terre par exemple
et en reste massif dans la ville
d'annecy avec 1800 texte est maintenant
et on voit bien que sur ces questions là
et c'est le girondin qui l'état est
parfois bien plus puissants que les
collectivités d'abord saint-laurent
banquiers ensuite je le dis très
clairement ce qu'il a fait en régional
rhône-alpes c'était utile et nécessaire
parce qu'il y avait une défaillance de
l'état sur les masques des tests je vais
pas y revenir ici elle est tournée un
pays qui testent le malus c'était en
europe
on aimerait des croyances sur les murs
est roland prolonger maintenant au
départ
rappelez-vous nord sinon à connaître la
vie qui a pas eu de défaillance sur une
à dix au départ ses comptes est collé
symptomatique et ont fait pas de test
massif pour rappelez vous c'était la
thèse du gouvernement et renault sur la
décentralisation c'est vrai donc moi je
suis pour les territoires je crois en la
france des territoires
on n'a jamais assisté à autant de
recentralisation que depuis le quinquina
d' emmanuel macron c'est ça la réalité
tout est centralisé et là encore dans la
loi décentralisation voulait re
centraliser le rsa qui est la compétence
des départements et donc moi je dis
aujourd'hui
là encore on peut faire des grands
débats au moment dé gilet jaune mais la
réalité ce sont les actes et les actes
concret et je suis sûr qu'au fond de
vous êtes d'accord avec moi il n'y a pas
eu d'actes nouveau de décentralisation
il n'y a pas eu de compétences partagées
il n'y a pas eu de renforcement des
dotations de l'état râler golic juste
ici quand on supprime la taxe
d'habitation très bien beaucoup de
français sont contents mais la réalité
c'est quoi ces cons assèche les communes
la réalité aujourd'hui on ne lève plus
l'impôt local et ses salles à moi je
crois la décentralisation le rend
l'action de proximité et je vous dire un
truc
franchement c'est que ce qui me fait le
plus mal dans ce mandat c'est la
déconnexion clients avec les territoires
la fracture territoriale c'est un enjeu
majeur sur le domaine médical sur le
domaine numérique sur tous les sujets je
moi je
soit c'est parce que je suis breton et
qu'on a une vision différente et un mode
de fonctionnement différent mais moi je
dois autonomes encore jeune on est loin
de la république française
et fier d'être dans la république
française en europe et avec notre
identité bretonne et effectivement on a
souvent demandé un certain nombre de 2
comment dire d'expérimentation et ça
marche très bien mais moi je n'ai pas du
tout cette version perception là déjà on
voit que massivement sur cette mandature
l'argent a été réinjectés dans les
collectivités locales contrairement aux
socialistes qui avaient supprimé 15
milliards de dotations voit bien que
voilà et aujourd'hui on a un projet de
loi il est
on va voir quand est-ce qu'on pourra le
faire aboutir le projet 4d sur la
différenciation où chaque territoire
pourra faire un certain temps je veux
juste une chose est donc est en
terminale confiance aux territoires mais
on fait confiance d'antoine chapelot
avait peur des territoires et de faire
confiance territoire ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire permettre par exemple sur
les politiques de vaccins de permettre
aux maires de déployer des centres de
vaccination ce qui s'est passé mais
c'est ce qui s'est passé enfin tout ce
qui s'est passé vous savez dans tous les
territoires de la force de réponse juste
juste impolis
moi je crois au développement économique
par les territoires et je crois
franchement que aujourd'hui non le
compte y est pas honnêtement le
maquereau nisme c'est quand même la
déconnexion totale avec les territoires
c'est quand même l'abandon de cette
france du temps c'est quand même
essentiellement à les anglais
d'opposition stérile mais on a quand
même plus parler aux métropoles qu'aux
territoires ruraux
regardez chez moi dans mon département
la politique vaccinale
il fallait qu'il y ait un certain nombre
pas comme partout on avait 10 100 1000
pour 100000 habitants 1 500 centres de
vaccination chez nous les que les élus
avec l'aide du préfet donc que l'on fait
le pouvoir central anciens de plus si
vous avez dit aujourd'hui vous avez bien
sûr c'est ça que vous êtes le seul but
le seul débat j'avais envie de savoir
s'il est bien que c'est pas et on fera
souvenir dans le finistère alors que 12
vous savez très bien que les doses c'est
pas une question c'est pas une faute du
gouvernement c'est juste une réalité
mondiale de la capacité à fournir à
savoir c'est la faute du gouvernement c
est ce que vous aviez ou non des doses
il en a partout il faut accélérer cette
politique de la ville pierre ouzoulias
si vous voulez évoquez vous un autre
aspect de la crise sanitaire
oui c'est ce que vivent les étudiants
c'est vrai qu'on n'en a pas parlé depuis
depuis le début de cette émission
et pourtant on avait toutes les images
en tête de ces étudiants qui font la
queue aux restos du coeur par exemple et
c'est là dessus que vous voulez interdir
fait intervenir des biens mais je crois
que membre ou encore être d'accord c'est
pas grave non dans dans la liste que
vous faisiez de ce que doit être un état
vous avez oublié l'éducation nationale
moi je l'inclus et n'aurait osé raison
on est d'accord
l'éducation nationale de la maternelle
trois ans jusqu'à l'université et
l'université inclus voilà est
aujourd'hui par rapport à ce service
public qui est déterminant parce qu'il
sait qu'il s'agit de l'enjeu de la
jeunesse il s'agit aussi de de faire que
la france se soit un pic connaissances
sur ce point il y à un abandon total on
arrive au temps du bilan
monsieur le député donc on a pu entendre
pendant un certain temps les grands
discours de communication la maintenance
et qu'est ce qui a été fait par ce
gouvernement pour les étudiants depuis
trois ans rien et on arrive dans une
situation qui est une situation
dramatique où les jeunes ont faim il ya
40% des étudiants qui vivent sous le
seuil de pauvreté
et ça n'arrive pas dans un ciel serein
il ya une dégradation de la condition
estudiantine qui est catastrophique est
un message abominable envoyer la
jeunesse mois comme cette image elle m'a
frappé elle a marqué beaucoup de
français j'ai hâte de voir tous ces
jeunes qui font la queue pour récupérer
un colis alimentaire
honnêtement c'est c'est le déclassement
c'est la fin d'un ascenseur social c'est
la fin de l'espoir
donc c'est dur je veux le dire ici je
crois que sur les écoles le gouvernement
ait raison jusqu'à maintenant de
maintenir des écoles ouvertes et ce que
je regrette c'est qu'on est pas traiter
de la même manière l'enseignement
supérieur que tout le reste c'est à dire
les écoles le collège et le lycée et je
trouve que l'enseignement supérieur a
été trop sacrifier pendant cette crise
sanitaire
moi je vous dis il ya un sujet
économique c'est vrai il ya aujourd'hui
un jeune sur deux quasiment qui pour
financer ses études doit faire un job
étudiant je fais une proposition très
concrète
je considère que toutes celles et tous
ceux qui ont bossé avant la crise
l'année d'avant la crise et puissent
avoir droit au chômage partiel
deuxième proposition très concrète je
souhaite qu on exonère de charges
sociales
l'ensemble des jeunes de moins de 25 ans
qui trouve là un emploi pendant cette
crise sanitaire pendant deux ans pour
relancer la machine économique et pour
permettre aux jeunes de donner un espoir
mais je veux vous le dire aussi c'est
pas qu'un sujet économique
c'est malheureusement aussi un sujet
psychologique et humain et donc moi je
souhaite que ce qu'a dit le président la
république
il s'est engagé à le faire c'est à dire
qu'ils aient au moins une journée par
semaine ou des étudiants puissent
retrouver des amphis qu'on le fasse
comment ça on le verra la part de migros
pouy mais il qu'on le fasse sur
l'ensemble des années parce que il ya
urgence à le faire moi le demander plein
honnêtement la misa sein d'un service
supérieur moi je connais même pas
surprenant la réalité c'est quoi c'est
que aujourd'hui on a besoin que au moins
une fois à deux fois par semaine pas
simplement les premières l'année mais
l'ensemble des étudiants de france
retrouve les amphis et les cours aussi
en garde et aucun respectant les gestes
barrière je vous présenterai fait des
grilles d'albeniz l'enseignement
supérieur qui était là il ya quelques
semaines sur ce plateau vous dire
j'étais quelque chose rabouli papineau
un point fondamental lors de la
discussion sur la loi de programmation
de la recherche ser est censé en
décembre au sénat maj avait proposé un
amendement pour apporter une aide
d'urgence à l'université j'aurais aimé
que la majorité sénatoriale de droite
votent avec moi cet amendement
je pense que c'était important dans le
moment d'apporter à du budget oui mais
encore une fois c'est pas simplement du
budget est regardé de regardons ce qui
se passe et 50 dans les mois ce qui me
frappe c'est quoi et c'est pour ça que
je le dis la mise enseignement supérieur
c'est que qu'est ce que vous voyez
aujourd'hui quand vous êtes en classes
préparatoires
quand vous êtes en bts vous pouvez
assister un certain nombre de cours
et quand vous êtes à l'université vous
avez droit à rien sauf que pierre aux
yeux et laissez vous auriez pu voter une
aide d'urgence mais c'était quoi cette
aide d'urgence et parce que nous nous on
est on est pour une aide qui vise à
l'insertion qui vise à repartir vers le
marché travail c'est pas simplement ont
par exemple je vous dis je vous parle
très franchement moi je suis contre un
revenu universel donné pour tout le
monde
à tout le monde dans leur départ le
dispositif cette aide d'urgence
ce que je peux vous dire simplement
c'est juste pour aider ces points oui
mais position entrée en crête sur lequel
je pense qu'on peut de vote on va faire
un détour maintenant par le figaro live
retrouver vincent roux bonsoir vincent
vous allez sentir en seconde année de
mende volley au coeur on ont mis en
avant sur le figaro live alors écoutez
il ya quelque chose qui a été très lu
très commentée c'est le coup d'état la
nuit dernier en birmanie
jean yves le drian a demandé la
libération immédiate de l'icône
démocratique hawks en dessous qui est de
vendre le respect du processus
démocratique et les résultats des
législatives du 8 novembre dernier
damien abad est ce que la france
doit-elle faire plus ou est-ce que la
france en fait trop non je crois que le
ministre des affaires étrangères a
raison on vous voyez on peut être dans
l'opposition et partager un certain
nombre de choses je crois qu'il faut
rappeler effectivement les principes
démocratiques et qui effectivement il
faut respecter les résultats des
élections respecter la démocratie on
sait que la birmanie
malheureusement est assez coutumière du
fait qu'il ya une réalité qui est celle
là tout ceci sur fond économique
d'économie parallèle et souterraines qui
est extrêmement importante
donc je le dis très clairement je crois
que le miz les affaires étrangères sur
ce point là a eu raison il n'a ni
trophée ni pas assez
est ce que vous vous comptez prendre une
initiative
une motion aveux alors je crois que ce
sera le débat qu'on aura en commission
des affaires étrangères parce que
aujourd'hui et on pourrait le faire moi
je souhaite peut-être qu'on puisse se
faire au parlement européen parce que
vous savez lire une motion oui une
notion parce qu'ici on a peu de moyens
de faire une motion on l'a fait pour
l'arménie avec ce conflit dans le haut
karabakh qui a été extrêmement sanglant
et donc pour nos amis arméniens là
malheureusement on n'a pas d'outil
juridique en tout cas nous à l'assemblée
nationale dans l'opposition pour le
faire mais peut-être qu'une initiative
qui ont eu chaud au sénat ce au
parlement européen pourrait être prise
parce que je pense que c'est important
de rappeler notre attachement état de
droit à la démocratie donc signifie-t-il
politique est prise mais j'y serai
favorable
merci vincent merci damien abad erwan
balanant pierre ouzoulias sont arrivés
au terme de cette émission jouer juste
en deux secondes si vous si vous avez
damien abad en face de vous il aura un
candidat à la présidentielle damien abad
c'est xavier bertrand il vous l'a dit
tout à l'heure c'est un bon candidat
pour vous moi c'est pas le c'est pas le
candidat de ma famille politique
[Musique]